but here to discuss the issue or
republican congressman Sean Duffy of
Wisconsin who voted for the bill and
radio talk show host garland Nixon thank
you both for being here
Sean congressman Duffy III was able to
serve with you and it's honor and
privilege to do so and I thank you for
joining us tonight now you voted for the
bill there's obviously a compelling
reason you did that why did you vote for
the bill so listen we're a situation
Jason where we have a dilapidated
military we have planes that can't fly
because we can't get spare parts we give
our military a mission to accomplish but
we don't give them the resources to
accomplish that mission the sequester
has crushed our ability to defend
ourselves and we have rising threats
whether it's China Russia North Korea
Iran and we passed a bill out of the
house that was conservative and I
supported that bill but as you know all
too well and I think your listeners hear
this quite a bit when our bill went to
the Senate you can't pass it with just
Republican votes you need Democrat votes
so Chuck Schumer to deliver votes
extracted additional spending and so we
had a choice in the house do we take the
deal that Chuck's room was through more
spending into but also gets our military
back on track to address the needs that
we have in the world or do we say no and
keep these these really horrible budget
caps in the military that don't let them
accomplish their mission and for me I
don't want the spending that fits in
this bill but I also want to make sure
our military men and women can defend us
and accomplish the mission that we give
them now garland how if you were in
Congress how would you vote it do you
think there was a good bill or would you
voted against it well of course if I was
in Congress I'd have been trying I have
been pushing to hold out for daca from
the left hand side from the left side
but you know my feeling is this I think
that you know in my opinion I think
there are some reductions that we could
do in the military and I think we could
have done that by bringing some of our
troops home by Afghanistan Afghanistan
but additionally I think it's kind of
disingenuous to say that you came up
with a bill and then you were shocked to
find out that there was another party in
Congress that you're gonna have to go
through I don't remember in my lifetime
when one party had super majorities in
both houses and the White House might
not the bargain for some Obamacare I
think think back of 2009 and 2010 and
they got Obamacare that a super majority
in the Senate
and shoved dodd-frank and Obamacare down
our throats yeah I mean they were able
to use the tool of reconciliation but
why didn't the Democrats unanimously
vote for this I mean there was nothing
that was cut of any substance and it
supported our military something I think
I thought Democrats were supportive of
but why and I understand the need to do
daca but I don't think you'd go any
further than what President Trump
speaker Ryan and Mitch McConnell have
done in saying we need to address it by
the way Barack Obama was president for
eight years they never addressed the
immigration I agree and I wish they had
have I wish they'd addressed it if they
had addressed it when they had the
majorities in the house but they didn't
so we are where we are now and the
problem is now from the the people that
didn't go for it that the Democrats
don't have any leverage for daca they
threw that all out so now they may not
even get anything so I think the
Democrats that held out it wasn't
because of the budget it was for other
reasons no your go ahead go ahead no we
can't fall into the trap of thinking
that the Democrats are supporting the
military they've been used in the
military at military as leverage to get
all kinds of other spending but if they
really cared about the military we could
have addressed this issue months ago and
given the military the resources they
need to accomplish the mission and to
come on here and say that they actually
are supporters of the military they
haven't been there worth goal and they
want to see military spending depleted
and they want us to pull out of very
rough regions of the world whether it's
Iraq or Afghanistan well we saw how well
that worked for us that was the rise of
Isis when Barack Obama pulled out and
left a vacuum in his place all of a
sudden you had people burning you know
burning their enemies and beheading
people we have to be smarter about our
policy and cut in the military is not
smart policy again with rising threats
that we have in the world I have to go
very quickly but congressman how do you
answer the question that Rand Paul was
out there saying look Republicans were
opposed to these deficits when President
Obama was in place but now that there
Donald Trump we seem to be okay with
trillion-dollar deficit next year how do
you answer so first of all you're using
growth numbers that are Obama girls
numbers when you get Trump growth
numbers at three and a half four four
and a half percent growth those deficits
aren't going to be that big but again
that's the problem when trucks
was a big spender in his leveraging the
military for for additional spending in
non-military defense non-military
discretionary spending that's that's the
deal that had to be made and again for
me this was a tough vote but I decided
with the military because I think that's
the most immediate threat we're gonna
have to deal with in one last point I
know you got to go if we're to deal with
that you have to deal with entitlements
entitlements are the key to reducing
this massive outflow in the government
and until you get to that you're not
going to address the massive deficit and
debt Thank You congressman I'll give you
the last word Paul Ryan the speaker has
said that he wants to address the
entitlement reform is that something
that you or the Democrats do you think
could get behind in support I certainly
hope you feel like I feel as though
there's the problem there's a problem I
hope not that's the problem is that to
suggest that we're actually going to
address entitlements that's gonna be the
problem I've got to leave it there thank
you work requirements don't it I thank
you I've got to go for Medicaid